[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi j'ai jamais vu un super héros au
moins la télé quand même
j'ai toujours voulu être un super héros
c'est un rêve dbs superman batman
spiderman le costume cintré qui fait les
basques la cape et la cape gélis
notation ne s'est pas pratique du tout
et s'est déjà retrouvé accroché
claude julien il est consacré dans ses
peintures
c'est comme être à là dans la soupe les
vêtements caméléon il change des motifs
en fonction des couleurs que j'utilise
s'il sentait camouflage la taille que
j'ai développé il somme par le passé
inaperçu quand j'ai activé le mode
furtif
on l'a bien sûr les modes n'est pas
activée a rappelé que vous voyez et sam
hd dans le noir de paix sociale alors
comme beaucoup de super héros j'ai un
fidèle acolyte de l'isère un peu sauvage
il a préféré rester à la tanière il vous
passez le bonjour ça faisait
j'ai bien sûr j'ai un super pouvoir le
rêve émission je sème des graines de
poésie dans le béton de l'entrée patch
comme beaucoup de ces périodes
l'été je suis à train atteint d'un
trouble incurable
je suis somnambule en scène une branche
orphelines et les somnambules artis mme
en fait quand je dors mal de raisons que
j'ai pas de phrase les animaux sont les
façades d'immeubles sur les murs dans la
ville alors où dd je pensais que c'était
seulement des rêves la peinture ça
laisse des traces
alors j'ai vite compris un jour comparé
la première fois en jeu découvrir ce que
je faisais la nuit je suis réveillée
comme ça ma tante c'est une sensation
bizarre
l envie d'aller vérifier de les jouer le
passé prendre une photo et les plis
châtelaine en bref c'est comme ça je
suis tout excité j'ai envie de maji
rapidement pour aller voir sur place en
plein jour ce que j'ai réalisé la nuit
on voit là encore je vous raconte pas au
niveau administratif
le casse-tête pour entrer dans l'es15
ici pas super héros tout le temps j'ai
une vie aussi le pape le boulot non plus
dans le cyber métier passion comme ça
n'était pas son père parfois c'est
dommage 24 équipes toujours équipé lui
goldberg
autre obligation journalières et
l'intervention nocturne ont fait au
niveau administratif ils ont dit que le
mieux pour moi c'était de nate dans la
case artistes alors voilà officiellement
les seuils supérieurs aux mentions
artiste est spécialisée en paix est même
en peinture monumentale nocturne et le
diplôme n'est pas assez reconnu on n'est
pas assez valorisé fabre est bien un
parcours de découverte du graffiti de la
peinture à part dans la vie de tous les
jours dans la rue où la marge
on fond d'une valise et nos milieu d'un
champ pourquoi donc on l'a
autant de pistes qui quoi comment
et puis pourquoi pas alors je me suis
changé à blaz abcès dos un nom d'artiste
war en référence aux missiles et des
marées
oui la musique riggleman découvrir le
graffiti c'est voir l'art autrement
c'est surtout faire l'art autrement pour
caricaturer l'art dit contemporain s'est
souvent fait repérer beaucoup de moyens
et le street art aux graffitis ce serait
faire le maximum avec les moyens du bord
c'est selon c'est dans une performance
en certaines du matériel bricoler se
tenter l'impossible et finalement c'est
l'heure d'aujourd'hui
découvrir le graffiti c'est aussi voir
la ville autrement c'est observer ces
surfaces son organisation c'est faire
des balades enchantée dans les lieux
abandonnés interdite ce sont repérés
grâce à telle tags sur tel honneur
dentelle riffs peindre en bâtiment c'est
le libérer de son énorme c'est lui
donner un visage
nous aurons des légendes hier à turin en
comblant au niveau coquelicot découvert
le graffiti c'est aussi suivre les
rebondissements dans ce jeu driver
nature ce jeu piste cette chasse au
trésor
j'étais seul dans ce money aussi
8 10 meur c'est exister
elle sera peut-être effacer rapidement
des ailes à exister
certains noms début elle reste gravé
dans leur mémoire à la suite et c'est là
qu'ils allaient le pas mal de mails des
gens qui déboule en train qui passe
devant tous les matins et tous les soirs
ça le faisait sourire
les six ont accompli
[Applaudissements]
nous avons que l'image existe sous leurs
ailes et valoir dans ma tête
on est toutes les autres en gestation de
nombreux paramètres sont en jeu le choix
des murs effet il est depuis longtemps
sur ma liste
ou bien j'ai découvert le jour même et
je dois j'ai envie de se balancer ce
soir c'est bon soir la météo est
favorable
je n'ai pas d'obligation en un matin je
prépare mon matériel en attendant ils en
viennent je me concentre le dise le
lisent mentalement
la créature qui va mettre le faut il s
est endormi je m'enfonce dans la nuit
j'oublie tous mes soucis
je retrouve le chat les chouettes les
rangs j'arrive au pied du mur au milieu
du temps à les coupes les éléments je
fais connaissance avec sa monumentalité
enfin présence qui s'étaient habitués
reviennent petit à petit jeu
l'apprivoiser je m'installe
koopmans j'attends je profite de ce
moment
de ce point de vue privilégié puis on de
partir tous ces maires les premiers
traits apparaissent la bête se profile
sont elles ne regardent déjà tandis que
son corps prend de l'épaisseur
je prends une dernière fois diront qu'il
est là pour vérifier que rire le manche
avoué libre j'aime échappe c'est elle
moi tu es loin
je sais pas si vous connaissez des cg
ceci après si on affiche changer quelque
chose
il serait illégal et les bonbons c'est
pourquoi la banque change de monde
il modifie notre rapport à la ville au
paysage avec la même place pour ceux qui
n'a pas pris c'est le retour du sauvage
dans les civilisations sans parler ni à
ceux ne pas laisser le monopole de
l'esthétique urbaine honte et militaires
ont un instructeur et mobilier en bois
dans les bus les critères ne sont pas
financiers c'est plutôt à une autre
époque
alors oui les taxes sont vécus comme une
agression
il ya comme quelque chose d'inutile
incompréhensible c'est tentant une
pratique intéressante à plusieurs points
de vue et plus qui ont été de la
peinture qui s'est plaint de tous ces
panneaux publicitaires qui ne bouchent
la vue
ils envahissent les cerveaux une façon
bien que sunrise
perso je préfère intégrer un coeur à
zizi ou n'importe quoi d'autre
tanger en graffiti c'est aussi découvrir
un monde secret c'est transgresser
l'interdît
ça me rappelle ma première arrestation
c'était les bibittes super héros c'était
un dimanche matin qui ont une page est
ce à dire blanche à l'arrière d'une
station-service ans qui dénonçait les
pertes humaines en mer il attendait dans
la voiture en me regardant fleurs
je vais réaliser ce qu'on appelle un
lettrage en inspirant des photos des
comptes des comptes et dans les
magazines
parce que à l'époque internet n'était
pas entré dans nos vies et à cette
époque là je l'utilisé pas encore maman
utilisent aujourd'hui
ici vous pouvez lire les lettres géantes
tch aucun signe et kong
j'étais fier de moi 1 sauf que la
station service ouverte
ces arrêts clients qui nous avait lancé
du coup la dînée père et moi on me dit
qu'on était à la gendarmerie pour
s'expliquer le propriétaire nous
demander une somme faramineuse bien
supérieure à celle de réparation du
préjudice
mon arc des faits j'étais bien en train
passe sur le but rennais se dédouane
mais je souhaitais pas il est aisé du
temps et puis je m'étais donné du mal
pour faire quelque chose de valable
et puis la signature est content de ce
n'était pas une insulte
j'étais juste une référence à quelqu'un
le plus marrant c'est qu'au moment de
relire la déposition
c'est mon père qui ont refusé de signer
est-ce qu'il était fier lobo dégradation
pour la loi ma première master piece est
considérée comme une dégradation
la vérité c'est que si j'avais voulu des
droits de jeu mais serait pris autrement
comme quoi tout dépend toujours des
points de vue qu'on d'en venir à banks
et je sais encore lui les
incontournables sa ville natale
bristol en angleterre quand elles
systématiquement c02 rôles qui sont
censés le prix des dalles lcd plus que
les banques s'il connaît ou peut-être
depuis qu'ils aient une valeur
commerciale
certaines de ses oeuvres sont même des
gouverneurs est vendu aux enchères pour
plusieurs centaines de dollars
tout ceci sous préfet et son verbe et
ces jeunes au passage l artiste ne
touche pas un centime
et surtout on ne demande pas son avis
dans cet art passionnant et paradoxal et
de côté plus de questions que de
réponses
la loi est-elle compétente pour dire ce
qu'il a est ce le marché qui est
compétent à conduire ce qu'il leur aura
t'il forcément une rumeur financière non
bâti le mythe il était notre fille tire
le street art sont ils une dégradation
il valeur ajoutée où il toujours dont je
ne saurais pas ses opinions
je ne sais pas si je suis un peu un camp
ou un artiste ou les deux et on va
toujours dit qu'il ne faut jamais je
venais à somnambule
alors si vous ne vous surprenez le
nombre perche 1 quelque part je n'ai pas
peur
rendez vous et reprenez votre rêve on
invente le symbole alors ces choses-là
n'attend pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]